xbox series s or xbox series x which is
right for you
to help answer that question i'm joined
by series
expert hussein absolutely moist
for the new consoles lads disgusting
moist should only ever be used if you're
talking about cake
and xbox series expert jordan remain
you're way too proud about this joke
you're way too happy about this
it's not even my joke not even my joke
this is evan's joke and it's too good
that we had to use it
all right uh obviously the new consoles
are coming out
series s has finally been confirmed the
two consoles
are very very similar so if you are kind
of humming and arriving about which one
to buy
this episode is for you we're going to
run through some very important criteria
to help you make the most informed
decision if you're thinking about
purchasing a next
gen xbox so let's get down to it
let's start with obviously the thing
that will be at the forefront of most
people's
minds the price so tam series s
big surprise you don't have to spur
loads of money for this console
it turns out it's only three hundred
dollars 2.99
that is an incredible price for a
console
um microsoft playing
big games here coming out strong that's
like nintendo console
levels of pricing like and they they
price things to move
so this thing like barring any major
kind of catastrophes is gonna sell a lot
of units
i would be i think a lot of people who
may have been considering getting an x
are probably looking at
this console the s now and going
especially
given some of the things we'll talk
about in the uh coming uh discussion
um a very impressive price point
obviously you don't have to pay it all
up front you can choose to do that if
you want but there is another
alternative which somehow turns out to
be cheaper
if you use all access you can pay 25
dollars a month for 24 months and
as part of that you also get game pass
ultimate
which now includes ea play um
so you can play all those games on pc
xbox through x cloud
and now they have the library of ea
games so a bunch of sports games jedi
fall in order star wars stuff plenty of
it
so no upfront cost you get a very
impressive suite of uh
services and it's all for 300
you actually save i think 60 dollars if
you uh go through all access rather than
paying for everything
separately so kind of seems like a
no-brainer so series
x though jordan so siriusx is the very
traditional console costing five hundred
dollars which
i think everyone was kind of expecting
going into this before microsoft even
announced that you're getting your
typical upgrade in
specs that comes with the next gen
console you're getting the disk drive
that you would normally expect the
series x is the
traditional you want your normal new
xbox and it's
normally traditionally cost at 500 for
something like that for a new console so
nothing surprising nothing really like
super
worth talking about as tam said the
series s is like this
incredible deal that's nintendo pricing
for a next-gen xbox console
series x is kind of more for the i would
say
maybe more hardcore xbox people who are
just like this is my primary
gaming machine and i want to put all my
money here
so it's 500 and all access of it is
available for the series x2
slightly more but at the same time
you're paying like 200 more console yeah
the one thing to consider is
it's cheap up front but you are locked
into a contract it works
the same way a mobile phone works it's
not a netflix style agreement where you
can cancel after a month
you are locked in for 24 months so you
need to be really sure that
you are committed to one that that game
pass subscription
and to that console um because if you
suddenly decide i want to move to an x
or i want to
you know there's another model that
appears which traditionally there are
like you
you won't be able to just split on on
your current existing contract you may
have to if it follows the mobile phone
model you may have to pay out the
remainder of the contract
unless microsoft are particularly um
giving and allow you to
give you an upgrade path but just be
sure that you want
to you're ready to be committed to that
for 24 months
so yes two different price points two
very similar consoles but let's talk
about
the key differences tam let's talk about
what's inside the box what's in the box
what's in the box what's in a
box so the first key difference is well
the first things to say is like there's
not that many differences
um which is perhaps the most surprising
part of the s versus the x you're not
losing that much
when it comes to power it mainly
pertains to resolution
in the differences between the two
consoles they have the same cpu
which is an important thing because it
means that developers
aren't effectively creating a different
version of the game that's going to be
massively hampered
with the difference actually is its
resolution so the
series s will output at 1440p
at 120 frames per second so it has
directx
array tracing it's got you know stuff
the bells and whistles that you want are
there
the main difference is 1440p in terms of
uh
resolution and then the 4k is upscaling
so it's not
native 4k that is pretty much
the main difference when it comes to
power and what that means for
resolution jordan series x then
as about to say like tam said it's
almost virtually the exact same thing
the only difference with the
series x is that you're actually getting
that native 4k
you're getting that pure 4k but
it's going to be like a very small
almost indiscernible difference i think
with most of the games that are coming
out around
the xbox series consoles but you've got
three times as many flops
got 12 teraflops compared to the series
ss4
okay and another key difference disc
tray
the series s nowhere to be found don't
need it
don't want it it's fine i mean i do want
it i do kind of have to say of course
you want it you still have physical
games
don't lie but the important thing is
like for people who
who want to buy the yes that's something
to definitely bear in mind because it
does limit
the things that you can do with it in
terms of obviously the
the physical game you can't put it in
but it means that you can't lend games
but also it means that you can't trade
games in and i know a lot of people
obviously are gonna they they consume
games by buying playing quickly
returning them to a retailer and getting
as much value as they can out of it
selling it on through you know
marketplaces or even you know lending it
to friends and family and that kind of
stuff
so if that's important to you then you
need to consider whether you want to buy
a different version
of the uh of the console um it seems
ironic that in this day and age people
are like maybe microsoft was interested
onto something when they were talking
about lending digital games and
check-ins and that kind of stuff so
perhaps the scope for microsoft to
introduce something like that later on
down the line
that is more in line with making that
possible
for um s owners but we'll see um
but then you also need to think about
the world wherein today or the world
will be in
when the game console the s is available
and the x is available
you're probably not visiting friends
that much
given the quarantine situation and
equally you're probably not going into
stores trading games in and also the
abundance of sales that are happening
right now on games digitally is
in like all the time and then on top of
that game pass
like you you're you're the chances that
you'd be doing or getting a physical
disc are much less
so that's something to also consider and
that's the thing really when you think
about game pass the last couple of
showcases that microsoft have had
they've been saying
huge games like fable things like halo
they're gonna be coming to game pass
day one so do i really need the disk
drive
that the series x has jordan yes because
if you're
like me you went into the xbox one
generation just thinking
you know wouldn't it be really really
cool if just this was the
first console generation where i didn't
sell any of my games
back to gamestop so almost everything
that i own
on xbox one is physical and i still have
pretty much
every single game except for one that
was
stolen so i just have like this
bookshelf this bookshelf that's full of
like
95 xbox one games just on disk and i'm
like
i don't want to lose them i need that
disk drive
all right console size jordan because we
know the exact dimensions of the series
x i'm going to come to you first
it's a chunky boy it's pretty big i mean
thick
extra thick yeah it's like the size of
what was it that peter used to say three
xbox controllers stacked on
top of each other and like two xbox
controllers deep one controller wide
one controller deep and then three
controllers stacked on top of each other
tall
like the the exact dimensions are like
15 by one centimeters by 15 by one
centimeters
by 30 centimeters i am fortunate enough
that i have an open
like dresser top that i put my consoles
on so i have space for this obelisk
for this fridge of an xbox but
does everyone like do you have space for
that do you know where you're going to
put it
i have space for it but not if i also
want
a playstation 5 which i do so i'm going
to have to figure out that
situation at some point in time so yeah
that's a very important thing to take
into consideration
that the what is it the series s
god the names man the names series s
tam how much smaller is it yeah it's 60
smaller but as i always say like it's
not about the size it's about what you
do with it and
i think that you have a lot more
opportunity to
kind of make that console easily fit
into your existing
um entertainment units and that kind of
stuff so
it's a very sleek looking machine i mean
i think they actually looks amazing as
well i really like both of them
um i'm i'm more into the x um just
because it's an imposing and scary
looking device that uh
i'm just gonna put it in the center of
my room so it's like a weird
like alien thing that i just have to
like pray to everyone that's because you
should pose all your figures to be like
around it yeah praying to it
all right let's talk about another key
difference between the two and that is
storage tam how much does the series s
have
it's got a cool 512
gigabytes of solid state hard drive
memory nothing can we just talk about
can we just talk about
cool cool expandable to one terabyte
ssd that expansion is ssd as well so it
will function the same way
that your internal storage does
admittedly not a lot of space there
considering
uh call of duty wall zone is
approximately 900 million megabytes
currently
megabytes gigabytes quadrillion
tetrabytes whatever that thing i don't
know what activision is shoving in there
um but it's massive so like
the thing to keep in mind is
theoretically um
the size of games should shrink the
reason games are so big now is because
developers are having to take assets and
double up or triple up on them
to try and make loading times reasonable
so it often has like duplicate files
everywhere in your game install with the
the the new drives and the cpu
processing power and the ram and that
kind of stuff working in tandem
it should be able to grab that data much
quicker and therefore they don't need to
double up and spread it out as much
so theoretically the idea is your game
installs
should get smaller or at the very least
stay the size that they are
um however you can also for both
consoles
um use a usb 3.1 i believe
a hard drive i think they have a
partnership with seagate
um to run your uh previous generation
xbox games which is nice that you can
create this like segregation of
old gen new gen however if you want to
leverage the velocity architecture on um
old games you need to have that on your
main drive it won't work on your usb
external expansion drive series x has
one terabyte terabyte i always want to
say tetrabyte which is
unlockable enormous like
but uh it's one of those things where
i'm like oh it's
so obvious obviously you want the one
terabyte
games are so huge and massive and at the
same time i'm thinking about them like
can't you fit like six to eight games
within like 500
gigabytes so it's it's one of those
things i'm like it's
it's really nice i like the idea of
having this huge hard drive that i can
store
like 12 to 16 games on that i'll be able
to just
instantly go back and forth between with
all of that like uh
pausing stuff that xbox has but
hopefully that's enough i don't want to
upgrade it was one of those things that
i remember when the xbox one came out
and they're like oh yeah 500 gigabytes
i'm like that's plenty of space and that
ended up not being
enough and so i had to upgrade to one
terabyte like let's hope that that stays
the case with
xbox series where it's like oh yeah one
terabyte that's fine it'll last you the
rest of the
console generation all right so the
other things to compare
you can't really compare because they're
the same so the series
the xbox series will support um
accessories from xbox one so if you
bought that elite series two controller
it will work
on your series s and your series x and
as well you get access to game pass you
get access to all the games
and the launch lineup which is looking
pretty good
growing in fact yeah like uh you
assassin's creed got brought forward um
it was originally gonna launch a few
days later but now it's gonna launch
on release day which is november 10th so
you've got things like
marvel's avengers yakuza like a dragon
assassin's creed uh watchdogs
uh fortnight obviously fifa nba
dirt gears tactics tetris effect and
falcone and
as we all expected making the jump from
pc to
console to the console that looks like a
pc yeah
also i don't think it's here but like at
some point microsoft flight simulator is
going to be available on console so
please be excited for flying but
basically you get the same
uh you get you can use the same
accessories and you get the same
launch lineup so those are the key
differences if you're in the market
for a new xbox tam i know we kind of
arbitrarily assigned you the series s
but which way are you leaning i am going
to be getting an x
because i'm a gamer i'm kidding no
because
i think i think like i the aesthetically
i think the most impressive
thing the big takeaway is how how
amazing it is that these two consoles
are effectively the same thing
and the price the price uh big off
is insane well see you later well see
you later
big golf song
hey guys oh big gulps huh all right
well see you later um
uh so so that's like i mean like i'm not
one to applaud corporations but well
played
field sponsors delivers for us that's
impressive
delivers smartly yeah big phil
killed it um but i'm getting an x jordan
a week ago i would have agreed with tam
but i think i'm gonna go with
series s honestly i think i'm gonna go
with the
cheaper smaller one and then put most of
the
money towards playstation 5 hoping that
within two or three years we get a new
xbox that i will then upgrade
to at that point but i i like
300 is a very attractive number for a
next-gen console and there's nothing
screaming at me at launch that makes me
think oh yeah i definitely
want the power of the series x for this
game
yeah i mean i am still very much
weighing it up in my mind but i think
ultimately i'll probably go
with series x and we were talking before
we shot
the episode but it's like just just
knowing that there's a more powerful
version out there it's like
inside my head i'm going but i want that
one
but also i would like to kind of future
proof um
for as long as i can um so
i i think i'm gonna go x also everything
is black in here so
aesthetics mate it's important that's
how i feel about my brother
i hate that there's a more powerful
version of me out there
all right that does it for this episode
of generation next
uh tam where are you on twitter i'm on
twitter right tomorrow h
jordan where are you on the twitters jm
remain
and i'm at lucy james games and we'll
see you next week maybe sony will
announce something
maybe i'll just like say i have two
brothers so
yeah the other one is watching you're
all so powerful i like you very much